[Music]
Joker is a reimagining of the origin
story of Batman's most famous foe it
contains references to many classic
films callbacks to the comics and some
hints about its shocking finale here's
everything you might have missed and
warning spoilers ahead the movies
specifically supposed to be set around
1981 later in the film we see a movie
theater marquee with the titles blowout
and Zorro the gay blade on it both of
these were actually released in 1981
speaking of Zorro in some of the comics
Bruce Wayne goes to see the Mark of
Zorro with his parents the night that
they are murdered when Joker's beaten up
by three men in suits on the train one
of them starts singing this song to him
[Music]
the song is called send in the clowns it
was originally written by Stephen
Sondheim for his 1973 musical A Little
Night Music
when Fleck performs at the comedy club
there's cameos from real-life comedians
Gary Gulman and Sam morale justin
theroux has a blanket you'll miss it
cameo as Ethan Chase the guest on the
episode of live with Murray Franklin
that Fleck watches as he practices for
his appearance on the show Fleck
performs at a comedy club called pogos
this might be a very dark nod to serial
killer John Wayne Gacy who was nicknamed
the killer clown and often dressed as a
clown character named Pogo at one point
Arthur practices with the gun he just
purchased before accidentally shooting a
hole in his livingroom wall he's
watching the 1937 Fred Astaire movie
shall we dance he's specifically
watching the performance of slap that
bass while Astaire was a legendary
dancer Phoenix cited ray Bolger as an
influence on the Joker's dance moves
while doing an interview with The
Associated Press later on in the film
flex sneaks in to a movie screening so
he can confront Thomas Wayne the movie
playing is the 1936 Charlie Chaplin
comedy modern times many locations call
back to the Batman universe both the
names slightly changed Arkham State
Hospital reflect meets with social
worker Deborah Kane is based off of
Arkham Asylum Kane is also featured as a
social worker in the comic book Batman
the ultimate evil
the name Kane pops up throughout the
Batman stories it's derived from Bob
Kane who co-created the character of
Batman when Arthur goes to find his
mom's records at Arkham Hospital the
clerk tells him that she was diagnosed
by dr. Benjamin stoner in the comics
stoner was a head doctor at Arkham
Asylum and later becomes a villain
meanwhile the Joker's origin story has
varied depending on the movie show or
comic the backstory of him as a
struggling comedian was also featured in
the 1988 Alan Moore graphic novel Batman
The Killing Joke which was later turned
into an animated movie starring Mark
Hamill even nervous and blue a punchline
the two detectives were constantly
questioning flak about whether he was
involved in the subway murders
named detective Burke and detective
Garrity perhaps Burke is based off of
detective Thomas Burke from some of the
comics and of course there's the Wayne
family when Fleck pays a visit to the
Wayne estate he first meets a young
Bruce Wayne we first say young Bruce
sliding down a pole a foreshadowing of
his future as Batman a butler of the
British accent then joins them it's very
clearly Alfred Pennyworth played by
Douglas Hodge and yes the movie does
build up to one of the defining events
of Bruce Wayne's life but we'll get to
that in a bit Joker doesn't just
reference Batman lore in the months
leading up to the movie director Todd
Phillips clearly stated to Martin
Scorsese movies as primary influence on
Joker 1976 is taxi driver in 1983 is the
king of comedy taxi driver stars Robert
De Niro as a cab driver named Travis
Bickle a disturbed loner who fantasizes
about cleaning up the city and
impressing a girl named Betsy in Joker
flick courts his neighbor Sophie played
by saucy beats both movies show scenes
where they're on dates and cafes early
on in the film Fleck and Sophie are
stuck in a very slow elevator in their
apartment building after getting out of
the elevator
flex shapes his fingers into a gun
symbol and points it at his head this
gesture is repeated several times
throughout the film at the end of taxi
driver after Bickle is shot in the neck
he famously makes a similar gesture
Fleck also takes his real gun and
pointed to his chin Bickle attempts to
kill himself this way in taxi driver
only to find the gun comes up empty like
Bickle Joker becomes an unlikely hero in
Gotham hailed as something of a
vigilante after committing an act of
violence in taxi driver Bickle stalks
Charles Palantine
a man who is running for president in
Joker flex stocks Thomas Wayne who's
running for mayor of Gotham City
meanwhile the King of Comedy largely
factors into the movie story flick is
obsessed with a late-night host named
Murray Franklin and dreams about being
on his show Franklin later shows a clip
of flex stand-up on air and
say the King of Comedy also stars Robert
DeNiro
he plays Rupert Pupkin and aspiring an
obsessive comedian who finally makes his
big TV debut after kidnapping his
favorite late-night host Jerry Langford
in one scene after Fleck is told that
he'll be on live with Murray Franklin he
starts the practice for his TV debut in
his mother's apartment this involves him
watching a taping of the show practicing
his entrance and pretending he's talking
with Murray it's very similar to the
scene from the king of comedy where
Pupkin makes an audition tape for the
show in his mother's basement when Fleck
is backstage at live with Murray
Franklin Murray comes to meet him where
Fleck is in full Joker makeup Fleck
asked Murray this can you introduce me
as Joker it mirrors this moment from the
King of Comedy now this is my
introduction and I like mr. Randall if
he could speak it word for word in one
of the film's most shocking moments the
Joker shoots Murray Franklin live on air
but it then cuts away to a shot of a
wall of TV's some of the TVs playing
news coverage of Murray's death others
display vintage commercials for
Budweiser Rolling Rock Kellogg's and
energizer as well as an anti-drug PSA
starring Clint Eastwood it closely
mirrors the ending of the 1976 movie
Network about a news anchor named Howard
Beale who becomes a hero to the masses
after delivering this rant on air he's
then exploited by TV executives for
ratings like Murray Beal is assassinated
on air the movie then cuts to four
monitors which flip between playing news
coverage of his death and commercials
flex awkward interview with Murray might
make you think back on walking Phoenix's
infamous interview with David Letterman
one major event that happens in the end
Thomas and Martha Wayne are shot in an
alleyway as young Bruce Wayne looks on
they aren't murdered by the Joker but
rather one of the many violent followers
in clown masks who fly conspires in
1989's Batman the Joker kills Bruce
Wayne's parents in Batman Begins as well
as many of the comics the Wayne's are
murdered by a man named Joe Chill this
be a reference to Joe Chill here as well
like in past versions of the murder
Martha Wayne's pearl necklace is ripped
off as the Joker's followers ride in
Gotham The Joker stands above them all
in smears blood on his face in a way
that mimics the characters iconic scars
will you look nervous
is it the scars know how I caught the
end meanwhile is left ambiguous did
Arthur flight 3 maul this up was the
Joker adopted was he Thomas Wayne's son
he see even really the Joker one hint
when we see Fleck running through Arkham
Hospital earlier in the movie everything
looks a lot dirtier in the end the same
hallways look pristine and white was
there anything we missed
let us know in the comments
[Music]